bonjour sert nicolas heureux de vous
retrouver ce matin sur rtl france
bonjour puis deux alors le gouvernement
annonce un que la cinquième vague est
déjà là que doit-on penser
et nous y revoilà mes chers amis de
fortune de la goutte d jean françois
delfraissy le grand mamamouchi lakovic
19 l'a assuré hier d'un matinale de
france inter la cinquième vague de kobe
19 est là et ça ne fait que commencer et
ça s'accélère alors dès aujourd'hui va
falloir attaché dacquois les sandales
sanitaire rock et les pulvérisateurs de
générer hydro alcoolique et faire un
trip ne soit manière de vos masques car
ça risque d'éternuer et de se moucher
bruyamment jusqu'au réveillon alors
selon jean françois delfraissy qui a dû
dépasser en terme de popularité chantal
goya et le club dorothée réunis on peut
craindre plus de 1000 hospitalisation
par jour voire plus d'ici le début du
mois de décembre et jean-françois n'y va
pas avec le dos de la seringue masque
vaccination et application stricte du
pas salutaire mais en a appris un truc
hier avec zorro masqué delfraissy à
savoir que la troisième dose et efficace
en 48 heures oui oui vous avez bien
entendu chers amis 48 heures rappelant
que pour les deux premières doors nous
disait qu'il fallait patienter grosso
modo entre une et deux semaines pour
constante et une réponse immunitaire est
bien là bam en 48 heures c'est réglé à
un clin d'oeil vous allez devenir le
gone de rack contre le coc vide en même
temps que le pire cauchemar du variant
delta delfraissy c'est nous parler à
nous français il avoue même toujours
masqué toujours sur france inter et je
cite il faut savoir utiliser les vaccins
car ils perdent une partie de leur
efficacité après cinq à six mois tout
l'intérêt d'une troisième dose et il
protège assez peu contre l'infection et
la transmission et jean françois
delfraissy et speed plus loin que je
cite toujours c'est difficile à
comprendre pour le public parce que
d'habitude vaccin protège contre la
transmission fin de citation alors vu
comme ça effectivement on est très loin
d être formation péremptoire prophétie
par olivier la science qui continue de
critiquer lui vigoureusement ceux qui se
posent la question de l'efficacité des
vaccins dans ce domaine en tout cas à ce
rythme là ya pas longtemps à attendre
pour que les vaccinés dans ce pays
reçoivent leur carte d'abonnement qui
pourra être couplée à la carte fidélité
de leur bd riad favorite en vue de leur
4e 2 olivier wiss effet derrière est
certain et il a craint en tout cas de
nouvelles mesures sanitaires restrictive
avec cette cinquième bague si en france
est bien le problème a glissé que sur
l'échelle de richter des mesures
liberticides on a quelques champions
d'europe en la matière pas trop loin de
chez nous bon on va passant par
l'australie à l'autre bout du monde qui
a décidé de transformer le pays en
placard pour non vaccinés et de faire
vérifier les fonds de gobelets de café
pour non port du masque plus près de
chez nous qu est ce qui se passait mais
l'autriche fait très fort depuis lundi
en confinant les non vaccinés alors ça
donne des policiers dans les monoprix
autrichien qui scanne et qr codes en
mairie aux chaussettes pendant que
d'autres vers est tiré par dont 10 et
sur la tête dressent des amendes au
rayon fromage et dans cette coupe du
monde des hommes mais si vite et
autoritaire le gouvernement français a
de quoi trouver l'inspiration même si
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire il
n'a pas fallu trop les poussez vous
repoussez justement les limites de
l'absurde et quand bruno le maire nous
dit il ya quelques jours comme n'est pas
encore là et bien on a quelques raisons
de s'inquiéter car bruno c'est un ballon
d'essai à lui tout seul alors en
slovénie c'est le passé dit est
obligatoire pour dupuis septembre
dernier pour récupérer 10 d'essence et
du côté de la lettonie qui se tirent la
bourre avec l'autriche à l'heureux les
députés non vaccinés ne pourront plus
voter ni participer au débat ou encore
toucher un salaire chez nos voisins
allemands le lander de la saxe a déjà
les deux pieds dans la glaise
l'autoritarisme en interdisant de
plusieurs activités oh non vaccinés
alors oui il y a des raisons de
s'inquiéter plus que jamais pour nos
libertés fondamentales
que certains sont prêts à liquider pour
un intérêt collectif très incertain et
bizarrement cela n'en ont pas fait des
caisses le faiseur gates a révélé le 2
novembre dernier par le prestigieux
british medical journal ou sur le très
sérieux rapport de l'apei h sur la
faible occupation dans les hôpitaux par
les passions qu'ovide lissée sur l'année
2020 tout comme les oublie de dire que
freezer biotech et bonnart n'a engrangé
écoutez bien un profit global de 65
dollars par minute grâce à leur vaccin
contre le connais dit 9 selon une étude
récente de people vaccinale et ans et
ceux qui vous c'est sur les réseaux
enchères nicolas on peut remarquer qu'il
ya une séquence qui vous a profondément
énervé ces derniers jours ah oui là je
suis chaque fois ce matin je suis sa
flore et pas je suis pas le seul
heureusement ça me rassure alors oui ça
s'est passé mon cher olivier ce mardi
soir à l'occasion du congrès des maires
gérald darmanin combier des élus des
hauts de france au ministère de
l'intérieur en présence de jean castex
premier et une vidéo où il avait dit a
filtré de cette soirée où ils se rendent
compte de poids qui n'y a aucun masque
pour qu'un gestes barrières on voit jean
castex il a serré des mains des élus
échanger avec eux au moins de 30 cm sans
protection alors que depuis faut pas
l'oublier depuis ce lundi 15 novembre le
masque bayonne à nouveau les enfants
dans toutes les écoles de france et bien
ce n'est pas acceptable c'est se moquer
délibérément des millions de français
qui vivent aujourd'hui un enfer de
contraintes depuis près de deux ans et
ils n'auraient pas tort de dire un de
ces français de se dire comme le faisait
son gamin et jean gabin pardon je cite
je boirai du lait le jour où les vaches
mangeront du réseau elle va voilà c'est
l'expression du jour merci beaucoup
merci nicolas vidal s'était l'édito
politique comme tous les jeudis dans la
matinale